map design has always been essential to
the successful flow of multiplayer
shooters but how do you create war zones
in which acrobatic pilots and hooking
mechanical robots both have their place
today on the next big game we break
apart the anatomy of a titanfall map
Thank You Johnny back now
fight and fall is a game where you play
each map in two fundamentally different
roles a person with a jetpack and a
massive mechanical robot so
fundamentally titanfall maps have to be
two levels in one on the pilot level you
have interiors with doors rooms
corridors you replaced hide from gunfire
corners to camp in and shelter from the
Titan fueled madness outside while as a
Titan the terrain and buildings act as
your corridors so pilots own the
interiors while Titans ruled the
outdoors so how do you level the playing
field once they meet in battle the key
it seems is verticality the maps in
titanfall have been built with vertical
pilot movement as a key component you
notice it the first few times you play
initially you will likely run into a
building and start running up stairs
like you would in any other first-person
shooter but once you start getting
comfortable with wall running the way
you look at each map changes reminiscent
of the verticality of classic
first-person shooters like unreal
tournament and quake and for the design
team the key to getting the players to
move this way was encouraging them to
look up if you have a mechanic like wall
running you need the psychologically the
player to feel like they can go there
there's this fine balance of the way we
design the surfaces of the buildings the
height I mean all the buildings are kind
of designed in such a way where you can
just barely make it with a double jump
in just the freedom you have as a pilot
being able to look at environments and
go to places that you've really never
been able to do and any other
first-person shooter feels great yeah
you have to realize that there's now
another dimension you can jump jump up
get to places where you couldn't before
in other games so I think it takes
people a little while to snap into that
you know some people get it really quick
some people takes you know an hour or
two before they're really know
comfortable with it and oh oh yeah
that's right I can jump up into that
window first thing I do is a player now
knowing the game the way I do is I'm
kind of looking at my options for wall
running and how I want to string things
together oh how on an ambush another
player is a tight and so we work really
hard all the textures all the geometry
kind of encourage those type that type
of thinking once people understand the
mechanics technical however as Titans
the maps feel totally different a
collection of routes and corridors which
bleed into larger areas that act as
flashpoints for combat evocative of the
lanes and squares in counter-strike and
this is no more apparent than when you
play the pilots or titans mode the tight
alleyways between buildings forcing you
to find cover right now we've only seen
two maps from titanfall so the question
remains how much more variety will we
see both in terms of map size and
variety now we definitely have some some
levels that we haven't found yet that
are a little bit different there's some
you know there's size difference
definitely you know in some respects you
want this area where the Titans can play
this area is where the pilots can play
and how those two they can't be separate
they have to there have to be some
interplay in between those so it's to
building these two levels that work very
well together some levels are a little
more open like fracture is a little more
open than Angel City which is very tight
though I think we have levels that are
even bigger than or more open than like
a fracture would be what we work towards
was to make sure that the levels had a
real real hard core identity to them and
they had a fiction behind it which goes
back into the campaign multiplayer there
is every with every level in the game
they each have their own fiction I mean
the concept of the environments is
really to build a relatable environment
player since we're asking so much of
them to learn all these new mechanics
give them an environment that they can
understand at the same time but always
feeling any used and lived in and not
pristine and clean
and that was the anatomy of a type of
format but we're not quite done with
respawn just yet tomorrow and the next
big game I sit down with respawn
co-founder Vincent Pella and ask him
about life after call of duty see you
then
you